wenn ich was esse vor der Kamera gibt's
immer blöde Screenshots
das weiß ich schon
[Musik]
es gibt sogar schon in unserer
whatsapp-gruppe in Sallys Welt und wenn
es Screenshots und Gifs von mir gemacht
und rumgeschickt
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
ja ich bin erkältet deswegen ist die
Stimme so rau ich bin noch ein bisschen
heiser ich war gestern krank aber heute
geht es mir wieder besser und ich habe
mir gedacht ich mache ein bisschen
Spritzgebäck für euch
so sieht's aus das sind
mandelspritzgebäck oh Gott die Stimme
die wird immer schlimmer das sind
mandelspritzgebäck und das sind
Plätzchen die ihr wirklich hervorragend
zubereiten könnt ist es wirklich eine
ganz kurze Zubereitungszeit nur
und ihr braucht auch nicht viel Werkzeug
dafür denn ihr braucht einfach nur eine
Rührschüssel und Handrührgerät und könnt
dann den Teig schnell verrühren da muss
auch auf nichts aufgepasst werden
anschließend nur einen Spritzbeutel und
fertig und das ganze dauert wirklich ich
verspreche es euch nicht länger als
zeige ich jetzt mal eine Stunde in der
Stunde habt ihr dieses Spritzgebäck
fertig
also ich zeige euch jetzt mal die
Zutaten für den Teig denn damit geht's
direkt los
dafür verwende ich 200 Gramm weiche
Butter 120 g Puderzucker etwas
Vanilleextrakt und Salz ein Ei 120 Gramm
gemahlene Mandeln 250 Gramm Mehl und 50
Gramm Milch oder Amaretto
hier könnt ihr auch gerne direkt die
doppelte Menge zubereiten denn dieses
Spritzgebäck ist wirklich einfach in der
Herstellung also hier nehmt ihr wirklich
weiche Butter verrührt das ganze dann
mit Puderzucker Salz und Vanilleextrakt
das muss jetzt auch nicht in der
Küchenmaschine sein könnte auch ein
Handrührgerät nehmen es muss nämlich
nicht cremig gerührt werden sondern
einfach nur das alles schön vermengt ist
und ich nehme jetzt hier Milch aber ihr
könnt auch ganz gerne Amaretto nehmen
das unterstützt so ein bisschen den
Mandelgeschmack noch ein bisschen mehr
oder ihr nehmt Amaretto der einfach
alkoholfrei ist es gibt auch oder ihr
könnt auch Bittermandelaroma nehmen
das jetzt darunter macht dann
gehe ich mal schöne dreckig
[Musik]
dann einfach die restlichen Zutaten und
kurz durchrühren
[Musik]
das ist jetzt der Rührteig und das ist
eigentlich auch so eine Art Grundrezept
ihr könnt nämlich statt Mandeln zum
Beispiel auch gemahlene Haselnüsse
nehmen könnt statt Amaretto auch etwas
Baileys dazu nehmen oder etwas Kaffee
könnt kaffeekringel machen ihr könnt
Babys kriegen machen können auch Kakao
mit zum Teig dazugeben also da seid ihr
echt total frei und es ist einfach ein
spritzteig den man mit dem Spritzbeutel
spritzen kann also nicht so fest dass
man ein Spritzgebäck Pistole da braucht
sondern oder
wie Fleischwolf mit Spritzgebäck Vorsatz
das kann man wirklich schön mit der
Spritztülle einfach machen ich nehme
jetzt hier eine 14 mm Sterntülle die
kommt hier in das warte
[Musik]
ich mache es dann immer so ich glaube
das ganze um da kommt es so in den
spritzbeutelständer rein
und dann der Teig
[Musik]
und jetzt zeige ich euch einen Trick wie
ihr es schaffen könnt perfekte Kreise zu
spritzen ohne was vorzuzeichnen auf
Backpapier ihr nehmt euch einfach ein
bisschen stärker
und ja ich bin mega erkältet noch
deswegen ist meine Stimme so
dann nehmt ihr euch einen Ausstecher der
hat jetzt hier 6 cm Durchmesser und Glas
geht aber auch und dann taucht ihr das
hier in die Stärke und könnt so eine
Markierung setzen
und das könnt ihr mit jeder beliebigen
Form machen auch bei makaros zum
Beispiel oder bei allem bei Windbeuteln
alles was quasi eine Form in der Form
gebracht werden muss kann somit schön
vorgezeichnet werden
ohne dass man eben einen Stift dafür
braucht
[Musik]
okay wenn oben habe ich jetzt auch
bereits vorgeheizt auf 170 Grad Heißluft
so kann ich nämlich mehrere Bleche
gleichzeitig backen und jetzt nehmt ihr
euch den Spritzbeutel und spritzt
einfach einen schönen Kringel
der Teig sollte jetzt nicht zu fest sein
aber auch nicht so flüssig dass er
später eben zerläuft er sollte schon
eine gewisse Festigkeit haben also ist
auch ein bisschen anstrengend das auch
zu spritzen aber es darf überhaupt nicht
zu fest sein dann sonst
meine Stimme die Stimme denn sonst ist
es einfach zu anstrengend aufzuspritzen
aber so ungefähr passt gut
[Musik]
die sind jetzt vorbereitet und kommen
bereits in den vorgeheizten Backofen bei
170 Grad Heißluft ich glaube ich kann
sogar alle drei gleichzeitig backen auf
den verschiedenen Ebenen und dann dauert
es so ungefähr 12 bis 14 Minuten je
nachdem wie euer Ofen backt und dann
nehme ich die Bleche immer andersrum
dann kann ich nämlich direkt hier drauf
ziehen
[Musik]
die Kekse sind jetzt gebacken ich habe
sie dann kurz auf dem Blech auskühlen
lassen und sie dann aufs einen
abkühlgitter gesetzt das ist auch immer
wichtig dass ihr da vorsichtig seid
damit sie nicht zerbrechen jetzt sind
sie jedenfalls komplett ausgekühlt und
ich kann mich jetzt um die Dekoration
und um die Fertigstellung kümmern dafür
nehme ich jetzt einfach etwas
Zartbitterkuvertüre und ich habe hier so
so ein Zucker Crunch der ist auch mit
Mandeln gemacht und ist einfach so ein
goldener streut Dekor der richtig lecker
ist und eben auch ganz gut noch mal
schmeckt passt also perfekt zum Rezept
ich habe jetzt hier schon mal 100 Gramm
Zartbitter Kuvertüre über dem warmen
Wasserbad geschmolzen
das kann ich jetzt hier runter nehmen
und dann noch mal 50 Gramm dazu rühren
so wird die Kuvertüre nämlich schön
temperaturiert bekommt später einen
schönen Glanz und eben keinen grauen
Schleim jetzt das hier kurz einrühren
und warten bis sie geschmolzen ist es
kann sein dass ihr noch mal kurz auf den
Herd muss also auf den Topf aber wenn
dann nur ganz kurz so für den Rest Hitze
zum noch mal bisschen erwärmen
[Musik]
und wenn ihr dann soweit seid nehmt ihr
euch einen abgekühlten Keks am besten
jetzt die Stelle eintauchen die so
dieser Übergang ist und dann einfach so
ein bisschen in die Schokolade tauchen
den Rest abtropfen lassen
dann noch ein paar Pringles oben drauf
und zum Abkühlen am besten auf eine
Dauerbackfolie das war's
und ich würde euch jetzt empfehlen falls
ihr gleich mehrere Plätzchen Sorten
macht die auch alle etwas Kuvertüre
brauchen dann schmilzt einfach ein
bisschen mehr Kuvertüre macht alles in
einem Schritt und dann habt ihr nicht
immer so viel Arbeit beim einzelnen
dekorieren könnte alles was mit
Schokolade zu tun hat in einem Durchgang
machen
super schöner
[Musik]
ich dachte kurz die Kuvertüre reicht
nicht aber
aber wenn ihr einen Teigschaber benutzt
und die restliche Kuvertüre auf den
restlichen Keks geht auf den einen am
Ende dann rechts genau und ihr habt dann
nichts übrig ist das nicht schön
[Musik]
das letzte Restle auf dem Löffel das ist
danach stresst den dürft ihr dann
einfach abschlecken mache ich jetzt
natürlich nicht jedenfalls sind die
Kekse jetzt fertig die lasse ich jetzt
hier bei Raumtemperatur abkühlen ihr
könnt aber auch kurz in den Kühlschrank
stellen und dann sind sie fertig und ich
habe ganz viele weitere Plätzchenrezepte
schon auf meinem Kanal da schaut ihr
gerne mal vorbei und wir probieren die
gleich sobald die Kuvertüre fest
geworden ist
jetzt sind die mandelringe fertig und
bei uns gibt es bei Plätzchen einen
abweisgebot man muss Plätzchen abbeißen
denn Murat der naschtee oft viel zu
schnell und ich finde es immer viel zu
schade also werden die gebissen
das nächste Mal drehe ich mir wieder weg
weil wenn ich was esse vor der Kamera
gibt's immer blöde Screenshots
jetzt weiß ich schon
es gibt sogar schon in unserer
whatsapp-gruppe in Sallys Welt und wenn
Screenshots und Gifs von mir gemacht und
vom geschickt
zur Gemeinde
dafür esse ich jetzt aber genüsslich
mein Plätzchen vor der Kamera
richtig lecker muss ich echt sagen und
vor allem
sehen die einfach schön aus ich finde
die sehen Ausweg gekaufte Plätzchen
richtig gut da könntet jetzt hübsch
verpacken in der Keksdose die sind auch
wirklich lange haltbar bis zur 6-8
Wochen also Plätzchen die gehen halt
auch nicht kaputt und dann könnt ihr sie
verschenken oder einfach selber naschen
zur Vorweihnachtszeit gell und dann
schaut ihr einfach noch auf meinem Blog
vorbei und in meiner App da gibt's
nämlich schon ganz viele
Plätzchenrezepte dir zubereiten könnt
Plätzchen die letzten Jahre schon
gemacht habe so richtig best of und da
gibt's ganz ganz tolle Ideen für jeden
was fruchtiges was glutenfreies no bake
etwas mit Ausstecherle Spritzgebäck also
da gibt es wirklich so alles was man
sich an Plätzchen nur wünschen kann und
ich glaube manchmal schon immer dass es
gar keine Plätzchen Rezepte mehr gibt
aber dann gibt es doch immer irgendwie
was was mir dann noch so einfach wird
also viel Spaß beim Nachbacken ich würde
mich jetzt glaube ich ein bisschen
bis zum nächsten Mal tschüss
[Musik]